This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm here with Emmett Fitzgerald, a 99PI producer, climate reporter, and as I've recently learned, a psychotic Arsenal fan. It's true. I've been mildly obsessed with the English Football Club Arsenal for basically my entire adult life. To be clear, I have zero connection to North London where the team is based, but for reasons I can barely remember now, 14-year-old me chose Arsenal and I've been living with the consequences ever since. You know, I wake up at like 6.30 in the morning basically every weekend to watch them play in Pacific Standard Time. That's lunatic behavior, but okay. I can, it's nice to have a hobby. Yeah, yeah, it's just my lot in life.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我旁边这位是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，他是99PI的制作人、气候记者，而且正如我最近才了解到的那样，他还是个狂热的阿森纳球迷。千真万确。基本上在我整个成年之后的人生里，我都对英格兰足球俱乐部阿森纳有着一种轻度的痴迷。坦白说，我对这支球队所在的北伦敦没有任何切实的联系，但出于我现在几乎记不清的原因，14岁那年的我选择了阿森纳，从那以后我便一直在承担这个选择带来的后果。你知道的，基本上每个周末我都会在太平洋标准时间早上6点半左右醒来，看他们踢球。这绝对是疯子一般的行为，不过好吧。我有这爱好也挺好的。对啊，对啊，这就是我命里注定的事。
Um, but anyway, today is a big day, because I have an Arsenal story for you. It starts with a match last season. Arsenal were beating Bournemouth 2-0, and in the 52nd minute Arsenal won a penalty. Now normally in a situation like this they would let their star player, this guy named Bukai Osaka, take the penalty kick. But on this day a lanky German named Kai Havertz stepped up.
嗯，不过无论如何，今天是个大日子，因为我有一个关于阿森纳的故事要讲给你听。故事要从上赛季的一场比赛说起。当时阿森纳以2比0领先伯恩茅斯，比赛进行到第52分钟，阿森纳获得了一个点球。按理说，在遇到这种状况时，他们通常会让当家球星——也就是那个叫布卡约·萨卡的小伙子来主罚点球。但在那天，一个身材高瘦的德国人——凯·哈弗茨站了出来。
So what's the significance of Kai Havertz and him taking the ball in this moment? So Kai Havertz had recently joined Arsenal from their London rivals Chelsea, and he cost a lot of money. He was the £60 million transfer. But so far that season he had still not scored a goal, and the football media was starting to chatter about how all that money had been a waste. So, you know, Havertz is looking a little bit nervous as he approached the ball,
那么，凯·哈弗茨在这个时候走出来主罚点球，有什么重大意义呢？因为凯·哈弗茨最近刚从他们的伦敦死敌切尔西转会加盟阿森纳，而且身价不菲。他是一笔高达6000万英镑的引援。但到那个赛季当时为止，他还没有为球队进过球，足球媒体开始议论纷纷，说这笔巨资全打水漂了。所以你看，哈弗茨走向皮球时，显得有点紧张，
but he smashed the penalty into the bottom left-hand corner. No problem. Kari Hamas announces himself as an Arsenal player. And the gun is made by three goals to nil. Now, this was not a particularly important goal in the season. It wasn't really even an important goal in the game, you know, it was like already over, but it was an important goal for Kai Havertz. And as he wheeled away into the corner to celebrate this, this with the Arsenal fans, a song starts ringing around
但他一脚怒射，将点球轰入了球门左下角。毫无悬念。凯·哈弗茨向世人宣告了自己作为阿森纳球员的到来。阿森纳三球领先。现在，这个进球在整个赛季中其实算不上什么特别重要的进球。在这场比赛里它甚至也谈不上有多重要，你懂的，当时比赛差不多已经失去悬念了，但对于凯·哈弗茨来说，这是一个至关重要的进球。当他一路小跑奔向角旗区，跟阿森纳球迷一起庆祝这一刻时，球场里响起了
the stadium. Does that mean anything to you? Do you recognize that? It means nothing to me. Okay, so that is, if you did not pick up on it, that is Shakira verse, the Arsenal fans sang a brand new set of lyrics celebrating Kai Havertz and basically saying, who's a waste of money now? Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey 60 million down the drain, Kai Havertz scores again.
一首歌。这对你有什么意义吗？你听得出来吗？这对我毫无意义。好吧，如果你没听出来的话，那其实是夏奇拉的旋律，阿森纳球迷为凯·哈弗茨创作了一套全新的歌词来为他庆祝，歌词大致意思是：现在谁才是水货？6000万打水漂，凯·哈弗茨再次破门。
A reference to the price tag that was paid for Kai Havertz and that was heavily criticized. And he does keep scoring. This is James McNicholas. I'm a sports writer. I work for the Athletic, where principally I cover Arsenal in the Premier League. And James says that on that day at Bournemouth,
这首歌暗指当年引进凯·哈弗茨时那笔曾饱受诟病的高昂身价。而且他进球的脚步根本停不下来。我是詹姆斯·麦克尼古拉斯。我是一名体育记者。我在《The Athletic》工作，主要负责报道英超联赛中的阿森纳。詹姆斯说，在伯恩茅斯的那个下午，
a new song was born. And now, basically every time that Kai Havertz scores a goal, the fans start singing their version of this Shakira classic. I've got to say, I've got an 18-month-old son, and that's certainly his favourite chant. Whenever that song comes on, or whenever I'm singing that around the house, he really enjoys that. So I do have a particular soft spot for that one. And when he says that one
一首新歌诞生了。如今，基本上只要凯·哈弗茨进一个球，球迷们就会开始高唱他们改编版的夏奇拉经典名曲。我得说，我有个18个月大的儿子，这绝对是他最喜欢的助威歌。每当这首歌响起来，或者每当我在家里哼唱这首歌时，他都开心得不行。所以我对这首歌确实有着一种特殊的喜爱。当他说这首歌时，
What he's implying here that there are a lot of songs like the Waka Waka Kai Havard song out there There are so many songs like this in the English Premier League There's no way I could possibly name them all but just to give you a quick taste of a couple of my favorites Arsenal used to have this handsome French striker named Olivier Giroud and the fans would sing his name to the tune of Hey Jude as in na na na na Giroud. One of my favorites of all time comes from West Ham who had this song for their striker Bobby Zamora that was lovingly making fun of the fact that a lot of his shots tended to sail way above the goal. It was sung to the tune of That's Amore, except it went,
他这里想表达的是，英超赛场上有许许多多像《Waka Waka》凯·哈弗茨版这样的歌曲。英超联赛里像这样的歌实在太多了，我根本不可能把它们一一列举出来，但为了让大家稍微领略一下其中几首我的最爱：阿森纳过去曾有过一位长相英俊的法国前锋，名叫奥利维尔·吉鲁，球迷们会借用披头士名曲《Hey Jude》的旋律来高唱他的名字，也就是“啦啦啦啦，吉鲁”。我最喜欢的经典之作之一来自西汉姆联，他们曾为队内的前锋鲍比·萨莫拉创作过这样一首歌，充满爱意地调侃了他的一大特点——他的很多射门往往都会高出横梁十万八千里。这首歌借用了名曲《That's Amore》的旋律，不过歌词被改成了：
When you're sat in rosette and the ball hits your head, that's Zamora. That's fantastic. That is truly just the tip of the iceberg. If you have your TV unmuted while you watch an English Premier League game, you're treated to a near constant chorus of songs like these. I think it's partly what makes the Premier League so special. These are songs with melodies borrowed from pop songs or folk songs and reworked lyrics, sometimes quite complex lyrics, which will be either to kind of eulogize their own players, lionize their own players, or are often quite derogatory about other players and other teams.
当你就座在前排，球却砸中了你的脑袋，那就是萨莫拉。这太棒了。这真的只是冰山一角。如果你在看英超比赛时没有把电视静音，你就会听到几乎连绵不绝的这种助威歌合唱。我认为这正是英超联赛如此与众不同的部分原因。这些歌曲的旋律借用了流行歌曲或民谣，并重新填了词，有时歌词还相当复杂，要么是为了赞美、颂扬他们自己的球员，要么往往对其他球员和球队充满了讽刺挖苦。
But the imagination and sense of humor of the British football fan knows few bounds. And you know, this obviously isn't unique to English soccer. Football fans all over the world sing during matches. And even American sports fans have some simple chance that they break out now and then. But I think English soccer singing has become almost like a folk art form. The songs have complicated melodies and clever lyrics, and each team has an entirely unique songbook that seemingly every fan in the stadium knows by heart. And I have to say, watching on TV from California, I've always been both
但英国足球迷的想象力和幽默感简直是没有边界的。而且你知道，这显然并非英格兰足球所独有。全世界的球迷在比赛期间都会唱歌。甚至美国体育迷偶尔也会喊上几句简单的口号。但我觉得英格兰足球的歌声几乎已经演变成了一种民间艺术形式。这些歌曲有着复杂的旋律和巧妙的歌词，每支球队都有一本独一无二的歌集，球场里的每一个球迷似乎都能倒背如流。而且我必须得说，在加利福尼亚通过电视观看比赛时，我一直都
mesmerized and confused by this whole phenomenon. Like, every time I watched an Arsenal game, it felt like there was a new song that didn't even exist the previous match. And somehow 40,000 fans just seemed to know exactly how and when to sing it. And so I went on a journey into the history of football fan culture and pop music to try and figure out how all this actually works. And who is even writing these songs that are perpetually bouncing around in my head. Okay, so where do you begin with this?
被这种奇特的现象弄得既着迷又糊涂。比如说，每次我看阿森纳的比赛时，总感觉都会冒出一首新歌，而这首歌在上场比赛时甚至还根本不存在。不知怎么的，四万名球迷似乎就能立刻心领神会地知道该怎么唱、在什么时候唱。于是我踏上了一段探索足球球迷文化与流行音乐历史的旅程，试图弄清楚这一切究竟是如何运作的。以及，到底是谁在创作这些总是在我脑海中盘旋的歌曲。好吧，那要从哪里开始了解呢？
Let's start with the football writer Andy Laun. I have always been fascinated by football crowds or soccer crowds and just the noise that they make. Andy is the author of We Lose Every Week, a history of football chanting. And he says that part of why he wanted to write the book in the first place is that singing soccer fans tend to get a pretty bad rap. I knew that a lot of the discourse around soccer fandom focused on hooliganism. A lot of the kind of times that football chanting made the news, it was for racism or for homophobia or for some really like dark, abusive, horrible stuff.
让我们从足球作家安迪·朗开始说起。我一直对足球观众或者说足球场上的群众以及他们制造出的噪音着迷不已。安迪是《我们每场都输：足球助威歌的历史》一书的作者。他说，他当初之所以想写这本书，部分原因在于唱歌的足球迷往往名声不太好。我深知围绕足球迷群体的许多讨论都聚焦于足球流氓行为。很多时候，足球助威歌登上新闻往往是因为种族主义、同性恋恐惧症，或者一些非常阴暗、具有攻击性、极其恶劣的事情。
Andy says that that part of football culture is unfortunately very real, but he also knew from a lifetime of experience inside football grounds that it wasn't the full story. Because I knew that chanting and singing and that kind of communal experience was much more than hooliganism. It was a way to express kind of civic pride and identity in something that you kind of really believed in. And I didn't think that that story was widely enough known. In his book, Andy traces the origins of football chants back to his own hometown of Norwich in the late 19th century. And back then, most cities had a bunch of different football clubs
安迪说，足球文化的这部分内容不幸地确非常真实，但他同时也从在足球场内浸润一生的经历中深知，这并非事情的全部。因为我深知助威、唱歌以及那种群体性的体验，远不止是足球流氓行为那么简单。它是表达一种公民自豪感的方式，也是对你真正信仰的事物的一种身份认同。我不认为这个故事被足够广泛地为人所知。在书中，安迪将足球助威歌的起源追溯到了19世纪末他自己的家乡诺里奇。而在那个时期，大多数城市都有好几家不同的足球俱乐部，
that were mostly connected to local employers. So for example, if you ever wondered where Arsenal got its name, the team was originally made up of workers from a munitions factory. Oh, I actually didn't know that. That makes sense. And in Norwich, where Andy was from, there were like six or seven different teams. So there was a team that was made up of employees from the Kaley's Chocolate Factory. There was a team made up of teachers. There was a team made up of people from the local church and they would play against each
它们大多与当地的雇主紧密相连。举个例子，如果你曾好奇阿森纳的名字是怎么来的，这支球队最初其实是由一家军火工厂的工人组成的。哦，我其实还真不知道这一点。这就说得通了。而在安迪的家乡诺里奇，当时大约有六七支不同的球队。有由凯利巧克力工厂员工组成的球队。有由老师们组成的球队。还有由当地教堂成员组成的球队，他们会在一个极具地方特色的联赛里互相交手。
other in a kind of hyper local league. In the 1890s a local Norwich man wrote a song called On The Ball City celebrating the fact that Norwich had so many football teams. And then a few years later, when those teams eventually merged to create Norwich City FC, they basically started singing that song as like an anthem for the new combined team. And it just became a tradition that kind of caught on. And that was in 1902.
在19世纪90年代，诺里奇当地的一位居民创作了一首名为《球在脚下的城市》的歌曲，来庆祝诺里奇拥有如此多的足球球队。几年后，当这些球队最终合并组建为诺里奇城足球俱乐部时，他们基本上就开始把这首歌当作这支新合并球队的队歌来唱。这逐渐演变成了一种流传开来的传统。那是1902年。
Now in 2025, it's still being sung by every game, four or five times in a game. On the ball city! Okay, so most people consider On the Ball City to be the first football song. But soon, fans of other teams followed suit and started singing songs meant to celebrate local pride. So for example, supporters of Portsmouth Football Club, which is nicknamed Pompey, started singing a song called Play Up Pompey. Which is a chant that's very simple.
如今到了2025年，每场比赛中依然会被人传唱四到五次。《球在脚下的城市》！好吧，所以大多数人都认为《球在脚下的城市》是第一首足球歌曲。但很快，其他球队的球迷也纷纷效仿，开始唱起旨在庆祝地方自豪感的歌曲。例如，朴茨茅斯足球俱乐部（绰号是“庞贝”）的支持者们开始唱起一首名为《加油，庞贝》的歌。这是一首非常简单的助威口号。
It's a bit more like a kind of a US chant. It's simply just play up, Pompey, Pompey, play up, play up, Pompey. The way they sing it chimed perfectly with the town hall bells that was next to the stadium. So it's that... Duh duh duh duh. Duh duh duh duh. I am a ballerina! I am a ballerina!
它更有点像那种美国式的口号。简单来说就是：加油，庞贝，庞贝，加油，加油，庞贝。他们唱这首歌的节奏与球场旁的市政厅钟声完美合拍。所以就是那种……哒哒哒哒。哒哒哒哒。我是一个芭蕾舞演员！我是一个芭蕾舞演员！
I am a ballerina! I am a ballerina! So you mentioned the first one sort of premiered around 1902. Where are we at this point where they start spreading around to other clubs? Yeah. I mean, kind of the early part of the 20th century, it was, it was this like, it was a phenomenon, but you know, the different teams would have them, they were often sung at the beginnings of games, like before anything even happened, it was kind of like the players
我是一个芭蕾舞演员！我是一个芭蕾舞演员！所以你提到第一首大约在1902年前后问世。那当它们开始向其他俱乐部传播时，我们大概发展到了什么阶段？嗯。我的意思是，在20世纪早期，这还只是一种现象，但你知道的，不同的球队会有各自的歌曲，它们通常在比赛开始时演唱，甚至在任何事情发生之前，就好像球员们正在走上球场时，大家会唱起我们家乡的歌，来庆祝地方自豪感。但我得说，如果我们打算把足球歌曲创作称作一种民间艺术形式，正如我在引言中所说的那样，我会认为直到20世纪60年代，这种形式才真正全速运转起来。这一切都在利物浦发生了。基本上发生的情况是，西拉·布莱克和披头士乐队成为了第一批闻名世界的音乐人。而且众所周知，他们正是来自利物浦。
are walking out onto the field, like let's sing the song from our town that, that celebrates local pride. But I would say that like, if we're going to call football songwriting a folk art form, as I did in the intro, I would say that, like, that didn't really kick into gear until the 1960s. And it all went down in Liverpool. And what essentially happened was Cilla Black and the Beatles were kind of the first musical acts that became world famous. And they were very, very famously from Liverpool.
与此同时，利物浦还拥有联赛中、乃至整个欧洲最顶级的足球队之一——利物浦足球俱乐部。这就使得这两者发生碰撞变得顺理成章。因此，利物浦的球迷将他们的歌曲作为表达自豪感和自我认同的载体，因为这里的人们取得了全球性的成功，他们是英格兰培育出的第一批全球超级巨星，而且他们来自利物浦，他们的口音听起来就像我们一样。于是，利物浦球迷在他们那座以狂热著称、名叫安菲尔德的主场比赛期间，开始直接原封不动地唱起披头士的歌。这是1964年安菲尔德喧闹的人群高唱披头士乐队歌曲《She Loves You》的片段。它本该属于我 呜！
And meanwhile, Liverpool also had one of the best football teams in the league, really in Europe, Liverpool FC. And it kind of, you know, it just kind of made sense that these two things would collide. So the Liverpool crowd used their songs as a vehicle for kind of pride and self identity because here are these people who are a global success, the first kind of global superstars
没有欺骗，耶，耶，耶 没有欺骗，耶，耶，耶 没有欺骗，耶，耶，耶 不，我的天哪 它本该属于我 但这个时期最具标志性的利物浦歌曲其实并不是披头士的歌。它叫《你永远不会独行》。嗯，你知道这首歌吗？我知道，但我真的只在这种语境下听过它。这个时期的歌曲其实并不是披头士的歌。它叫《你永远不会独行》。
that certainly England has produced, and they're from Liverpool and they sound like us. And so Liverpool fans just started singing Beatles songs verbatim during home matches at their famously loud stadium, which is called Anfield. Here is a clip from 1964 of the raucous Anfield crowd singing She Loves You by the Beatles. It should be mine Woo!
你知道这首歌吗？我知道，但我真的只在这种语境下听过它。我不知道它究竟源自哪里。好吧，它最初是为罗杰斯与汉默斯坦的音乐剧创作的，但让这首歌名声大噪的是一支名叫“杰里与和平缔造者”的利物浦摇滚乐队。名叫“杰里与和平缔造者”。我绝不想
No cheating, yeah, yeah, yeah No cheating, yeah, yeah, yeah No cheating, yeah, yeah, yeah No, my God It should be mine But the most iconic Liverpool song from this area isn't actually a Beatles song. It's called You'll Never Walk Alone. Um, do you know that song? I know it, but I really only know it in this context. song from this area isn't actually a Beatles song. It's called You'll Never Walk Alone.
我想这可不完全是什么热血沸腾的体育场嗨曲。你知道我的意思吗？就像……哈哈哈哈。好吧，确实如此，但你听听利物浦球迷是怎么唱它的。（“利物浦队歌”）哦，太棒了。你绝对猜不到这首歌能被演绎成这样，但它实际呈现出来的效果真的是太好了。
Do you know that song? I know it, but I really only know it in this context. I don't know where it originates from. Well, it was originally written for a Rodgers and Hammerstein musical, but the song was made famous by a Liverpool rock band called Jerry and the Pacemakers. called Jerry and the Pacemakers. I do never want
完全如此，完全如此。这已经成了利物浦闻名全世界的队歌。如果你告诉别人你是利物浦球迷，他们会在机场之类的地方冲口而出向你高唱《你永远不会独行》。所以你看，没过多久，其他俱乐部就开始注意到利物浦那边正在发生的变化了。
I want It's not exactly a jock jam. You know what I'm saying? Like... Hahaha. Okay, yes, but listen to the Liverpool crowd sing it. ["Liverpool's Anthem"] Oh, it's so good. You would never predict that for that song, but it actually comes off so well.
来自全国各地的球队来到安菲尔德做客，当他们的球迷抵达时，不仅会发现这支利物浦队是他们交手过的最强球队之一，而且还会看到一排排疯狂的利物浦球迷正声嘶力竭地高唱着披头士的歌。球迷们从这里汲取了灵感：这些家伙在唱流行歌曲，而且声音超级响亮，现场氛围好玩极了，球队还在赢球。我们在主场也能这么干。我的意思是，这倒都挺好，但可不是每个城镇的口袋里都揣着一支披头士乐队。
Totally, totally. And that has become like Liverpool's anthem that's known all around the world. Like if you tell someone you're a Liverpool fan, they'll start singing. They'll never walk alone at you in like an airport. And so, you know, it wasn't long before other clubs started taking notice of what was going on in Liverpool.
对啊，对啊，没毛病，没毛病。没错，我的意思是，在伍尔弗汉普顿、伯恩茅斯，或者干脆说在诺里奇，要想把所有乐队那些世界闻名的歌都唱一遍，祝你好运吧。我们那儿可不一定能找出一位闻名世界的诺里奇本土艺术家。那我们该怎么办呢？
Teams, you know, from all over the country would come to Anfield and when their fans arrived, you know, not only is this team, this Liverpool team, one of the best teams we've ever played against, but there are rows and rows of these crazy Liverpool fans just like singing Beatles songs at the top of their lungs. And fans kind of took that inspiration, like these guys are singing pop songs and they're really loud
嗯，我们或许可以改改歌词，这样就能用同一个曲调了。所有人都会这个曲调。谁都不用去学旋律。所有人都会这个曲调。我们直接唱就行，但我们可以把词改了，变成我们自己的歌词。”所以，这就是球迷们开始创作属于他们自己的足球专属混音歌曲的时刻——他们采用耳熟能详的流行乐旋律，并针对他们特定的城市或足球俱乐部重新填词。因此，歌曲本身并非来自某座特定的城市，但现在它有了新的歌词，可能是在赞美诺里奇有多棒，诸如此类。
and it's a really fun environment and the team are winning. We can do that at home. I mean that's all fine and good but not every town has a Beatles in their back pocket. Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly. Right, I mean like good luck singing all the world famous songs from all the bands in Wolverhampton or Bournemouth or Norwich for that matter. We don't necessarily have an artist that is from Norwich who is world famous. So what can we do?
没错，没错。或者赞美他们的球队在球场上的表现有多出色。以阿森纳为例，球迷们创作了一首经典歌曲，来赞颂球队的防守有多么顽强。一首诞生于80年代末90年代初的歌曲是《阿森纳1比0》，我记得这首歌借用了宠物店男孩乐队的《Go West》的旋律。这首歌成为了阿森纳最具代表性的
Well, we can maybe change the words of the song so we can have the same tune. Everyone knows this tune. No one needs to learn the tune. Everyone knows this tune. We can just sing it, but we can change it and make it our own words." So this is the moment when fans start making their own football-specific remixes, taking well-known pop melodies and writing their own lyrics to suit their particular city or their football club. So the song itself isn't from a particular city, but now it has new lyrics that might be about how great Norwich
助威歌。我之所以喜欢它，是因为1比0这个比分——我相信你们美国的听众会对如此沉闷的比分嗤之以鼻。这就是足球的问题所在，对吧？进球不够多。而在90年代，阿森纳曾遭到批评，基本上是因为他们的比赛过程太无聊，因为他们赢下的很多比赛都是1比0。而阿森纳球迷不愧是阿森纳球迷，他们把这种批评转化成了积极的因素，
is or whatever. Right, right. Or how good their team is on the pitch. For example, in the case of Arsenal, the fans wrote a classic song celebrating how tough the team's defense was. One which came out of the late 80s, early 90s is One-Nil to the Arsenal, which I believe is to the tune of Go West by the Pet Shop Boys. And that became kind of the quintessential
他们顶住压力，并为这种身份认同感到自豪。他们要成为联赛中最吝啬、最凶悍、最难被攻破的球队，并且要庆祝阿森纳每一次1比0的胜利。他们通过歌声做到了这一点。没错。能来几句吗？我以前在播客里听过你唱歌。好吧。我给你们吼一段。所以很显然，就是《阿森纳1比0，阿森纳1比0，阿森纳1比0》。给阿森纳，1比0。听着，从歌词上讲，它算不上最复杂，但你能明白它为什么能流行开来。
Arsenal chant. And the reason I love it is because 1-0, I mean I'm sure your American listeners will turn up their noses at a score line as dour as that. That's the problem with soccer, right? Not enough goals. And back in the 90s Arsenal was getting criticized, you know, essentially for being boring to watch because they won so many of their games one to nil. And Arsenal fans, being what they are, you know, they turned that into a positive
我的意思是，它至少比单纯喊“防守”要高明得多。没错，完全正确。而且你知道，当时的诀窍就在于简单。那时候没有互联网，没有社交媒体。这些歌曲必须在现实世界中病毒式传播。你可以想象一下这会是怎样一番场景：如果你是球场里一个死忠球迷，你基本上必须得把你的新歌唱得足够大声、足够清晰，好让你身边的酒鬼球迷们学会，
and they dug their heels in and were proud of that identity. They were going to be the meanest, nastiest, toughest to break down team in the league and celebrate every one of those 1-0 to the Arsenal wins. And they did that through songs. Yeah. Can we get a few bars? I've heard you sing on the podcast before. Okay. I'll give you a blast. So obviously it's 1-0 to the Arsenal, 1-0 to the Arsenal, 1-0. To the Arsenal, 1-0. Listen, lyrically, it's not the most complex, but you can see why it caught on.
然后祈祷他们能唱得足够大声、足够清晰，好让他们身边的酒鬼球迷也学会，接着再祈祷他们身边的酒鬼球迷也能跟着唱。他们又不会分发歌单或者别的什么，也没有什么赞美诗手册，对吧？你得回去问你的死党们，他们到底唱的是什么？歌词是什么？或者干脆多去现场几次，慢慢就耳濡目染地学会了。鉴于这种情况，任何歌曲能被学会简直都堪称奇迹。
I mean, it's still a far sight better than just defense. Yeah, exactly. And, you know, simplicity was key back then. There was, you know, there's no internet, no social media. These songs needed to go viral in the real world. And you can kind of imagine how this might play out. Like, if you were a die-hard fan in the stadium, you would basically need to sing your new song loudly enough and clearly enough that the drunk guys next to you would pick it up,
完全如此，完全如此。但随着时间的推移，这种绝妙的流行音乐填词方式确实在整个足球界传开了。而且由于这些歌曲是在比赛进行过程中高唱的，它让看台上的观众与球场上发生的事情之间的关系变得更加充满活力。没错，观众和球员之间存在着那种共生关系。有时他们会互相激励。可能是球队陷入了困境。可能是他们需要振作起来，而一首气势磅礴的队歌或许就能成为激励他们、唤醒他们的力量。或者当球队进球时，球迷们可能会开始高唱专门献给进球球员的歌曲。
and then hope that they sang it loudly enough and clearly enough that the drunk guys next to you would pick it up and then hope that they sang it loudly enough and clearly enough that the drunk fans next to them caught on. They don't hand out a song sheet or anything you know there's not a hymn book right you have to go away and ask your mates what do they actually sing what the words there or just come back enough times that you slowly pick it up. Given that it's kind of amazing that any songs got learned at all. Totally, totally. But over time, this kind of clever pop music songwriting really spread all throughout football. And because these songs were sung during the game itself, it made the relationship between
例如，在90年代末、2000年代初，阿森纳拥有一位名叫帕特里克·维埃拉的传奇中场。他是法国人，但出生在塞内加尔。他有一首改编自某首歌的助威歌，我记得那首歌好像叫《维拉雷》，歌词是这样的，我给你们唱一段。歌词是：维埃拉，哦，维埃拉，哦，他来自塞内加尔，他为阿森纳踢球。维埃拉，哦，维埃拉，哦，
the crowd and what was happening on the field so much more dynamic. Yeah, there is that kind of symbioticism between the crowd and the players. And sometimes they feed each other. You know, it might be that the team is struggling. It might be that they need picking up and maybe an anthemic song could be what lifts them, what rouses them. Or when a team scored, the fans might start singing a song devoted specifically to the player who got the goal.
他来自塞内加尔。太惊艳了。但我猜并不是每个球员都能配得上一首专属歌曲。哦，不，不，不。这是需要你去挣来的。当你从球迷那里获得属于你自己的专属歌曲的那一刻，就好像宣告你真正踢出了名堂。而且我认为这需要一些时间。球场词作家们必须退居幕后，闭门苦思冥想，创作出一些东西，然后
So for example, in the late nins, early 2000s, Arsenal had this legendary midfielder named Patrick Vieira. He was French, but he was born in Senegal. And he had a chant to the tune of, I believe the song is called Velare, which was, I'll sing it for you. It went, Vieira, whoa, Viera, whoa, he comes from Senegal, he plays for Arsenal. Viera, whoa, Viera, whoa,
这首歌还得能够流行开来。但对球员来说，那一定是一个美妙绝伦的时刻，这也是球员们经常津津乐道的事情。你知道的，我第一次听到球迷唱起我的名字。有一件事一直让我这个周末看电视时对那些助威歌感到困惑，那就是这些歌曲
he comes from Senegal. That's amazing. But I take it not every player warrants a special song. Oh, no, no, no. It's something that you have to earn. The moment where you get your own song from your fans is like when you've arrived. And I think it takes some time. The stadium lyricists have to go away, squirrel away, and come up with something, and then
似乎都是凭空冒出来的。这周还没有这首歌，下周就有成千上万的人齐声高喊了。所以在休息之后，将由我与一位把这种魔法变成现实的歌曲创作支持者聊一聊。好了，请不要走开。欢迎回来，我们将继续与埃米特一起探讨足球歌曲的起源。自从我开始做这篇报道以来，我一直想弄清楚，究竟是谁在创作所有这些仿佛像魔法一样从看台的混乱中迸发出来的歌曲。
it's got to catch on. But that, it must be a wonderful moment for a player, and it's something players often talk about. You know, I heard the fan sing my name for the first time. ["Sweet Home Alone"] One thing that has consistently baffled me about the chance that I hear on TV every weekend is the fact that these songs
而这次搜寻让我找到了一位名叫丹·冈宁的阿森纳球迷。这一切的开始是因为我们作为一个群体，想要尝试改善现场气氛。这是一个循环，对吧？球迷唱得更多，这能帮助球员。球员赢球，球员赢球，球迷唱得更多，就这样周而复始。丹是球场一个非常著名的区域——北看台的季票持有者。而且，你知道的，他是阿森纳比赛的常客。
just seem to pop out of thin air. One week a song doesn't exist, and the next, tens of thousands of people are screaming it in unison. So after the break, I will talk with one of the songwriting supporters who make that magic happen. Alright, stay tuned. Okay, we are back with Emmett to try to understand the origins of soccer songs. So since I started reporting this piece, I've wanted to try and figure out who was actually writing all of these songs that seem to spring forth from the chaos of the crowd like magic.
必须得说的是，阿森纳过去从来不以看台氛围特别火爆著称。他们可比不上利物浦。但在疫情后球迷被允许重返球场时，阿森纳踢得非常出色。当时大家齐心协力，试图改善球场内的氛围，努力在球场内部营造出一种绝佳的氛围感。嗯哼。
And that search led me to an Arsenal fan named Dan Gunning. It started because as a group we wanted to try and improve the atmosphere. It's circular right? The fans sing more, it helps the players. Players win, players win, the fans sing more, it goes round and round. Dan is a season ticket holder in this very famous part of the stadium called the North Bank. And, you know, he's a regular at Arsenal games.
丹和他的朋友们也是其中的一员，他们决定身体力行，为球队的一些新援创作一些新鲜的歌曲。我们开始听到球迷们的呼声，说这个人需要一首歌，或者那个人需要一首歌。具体来说，丹认为球队非常急需一首属于他们的新队长——一位名叫马丁·厄德高的挪威中场的歌曲。
And it must be said that Arsenal have never been known for being a particularly rowdy crowd. They're not Liverpool. But when fans were let back into the stadium after Covid, Arsenal was playing really well. And there was this concerted effort to try and improve the atmosphere inside the ground, try and really create, you know, a vibe inside that stadium. Mm-hmm.
厄德高是个技术极其娴熟、长着一张娃娃脸的斯堪的纳维亚人，身披8号球衣。嗯，当时我基本上就坐在床上，在YouTube上看飞镖比赛，飞镖比赛的主题曲就在我脑子里盘旋。等等，他是说看飞镖比赛就像在YouTube上看别人扔飞镖？他看的就是这个吗？对，对，对，你看。你知道的，飞镖是一项很受欢迎的观赏性体育运动，英国会在电视上转播，而主要的飞镖电视节目的主题曲是由一个叫“太空放克”的乐队创作的。歌名叫《逐日》。
Dan and his friends were a part of that, and they decided to take it upon themselves to write some fresh songs for some of the team's newest players. We start to get some noise from fans saying, you know, well, this person needs a song or that person needs a song. Specifically, Dan thought that the team really desperately needed a song for their new captain, who is a Norwegian midfielder named Martin Odegaard.
然后我把它发到了群聊里，问大家觉得用这个来改编一首足球歌怎么样？他在北伦敦的朋友们一致表示赞同。这是一个非常精明的选择，因为这首歌在北伦敦有着特殊的共鸣，我甚至可以说，因为这里每年都会举办盛大的飞镖比赛，地点就在亚历山大宫，距离球场只有大约20分钟的路程。
Odegaard is this incredibly skilled, kind of baby-faced Scandinavian who wears the number eight jersey. Um, was basically just sitting there in bed and I was watching darts on YouTube and the darts song was in my head. Wait, so he's saying watching darts like watching people throw darts on YouTube? Is that what he's watching? Yeah, yeah, yeah, you did. You know, darts is like a popular spectator sport and they televise it in the UK and the theme song for the main darts television program is by a band called Planet Funk. It's called Chase the
所以这是一首大家耳熟能详的歌曲，我认为这可能加速了人们接受它的速度。于是丹针对马丁·厄德高创作了一些专属歌词，来契合那个飞镖比赛的曲调。他实际上——我曾试图让他唱给我听，但他觉得在广播里唱太尴尬了，不过詹姆斯帮了我一把。我想他整天都在梦想着我们的8号，马丁·厄德高，当他在盘带的时候。
Sun. And then I put in the group chat and said what do you guys think about a football song for this? And his North London friends were universally into it. It was a very astute choice, because that song has a particular resonance in North London, I would say even, because every year, there's the big dance competition here at Alexandra Palace, which is only about 20 minutes from the stadium.
我发誓。我不知道。对，你可以说脏话。好吧。当他在盘带时，他简直像有魔法一样。马丁·厄德高。这歌词……有点拗口，对吧？内容挺多的。
And so it was a song people knew really well, which I think probably accelerated the rate at which people embraced it. So Dan comes up with some Martin Odegaard specific lyrics to match that darts tune. He was actually, I tried to get him to sing it but he was too embarrassed to sing it for me on the radio but James helped me out. I think it's been dreaming all day about our number eight, Martin Odegaard when he's on the ball.
对于一个喝了酒的足球迷来说，要记住这么多词可不容易。但在当今时代，像丹这样的词作家拥有一个顺手的工具，那就是社交媒体的力量。在这种情况下，丹基本上只是在推特上发了一段视频，把他的新歌词滚动显示在飞镖歌曲的音频背景上。他上床睡觉，第二天早上醒来时，他的手机已经炸锅了。我在想，天哪，发生什么事了？打开推特，到处都是点赞、转发、贴子和评论。
I swear. I don't know. Yeah, you can swear. Okay. When he's on the ball, he's magical. Martin Odegaard. Like that's, that's a mouthful, right? That's a lot.
当然，群聊里的伙计们也是如此，发来消息说：“这彻底疯了，到处都在传。”第二天是一场对阵埃弗顿的主场比赛。丹呢，他按照以往的赛前惯例，去酒吧喝了一杯。在酒吧里，一群朋友开始唱起马丁·厄德高的歌。很多人从推特上认出了这首歌，然后，你知道的，它开始流行起来。所以这是在它甚至还没有在比赛中被强化之前，它就已经在酒吧里唱响了。
That's a lot for an inebriated football fan to remember. But in today's day and age, songwriters like Dan have a tool at their disposal, which is the power of social media. And in this case, Dan basically just posted a video on Twitter with his new lyrics rolling over the audio track of the darts song. He went to bed and woke up the next morning and his phone had blown up. I'm thinking, God, what's happened? Yeah, open Twitter and just likes, retweets, posts, comments everywhere.
没错，没错。于是丹离开了酒吧，这首歌便从那里继续传播开来。在走向球场的路上，他听到更多人在唱这首歌。但最大的问题在于，他和他的朋友们能否在真正的比赛中——比如在球场里——把这首歌带动起来。
And obviously the same from the lads in the group chats, messages saying like, it's gone absolutely mad, it's gone everywhere. The next day was a home game against Everton. And Dan, you know, followed his usual pre-match routine and went to the pub for a drink. And at the bar, a bunch of friends started singing the Martin Odegaard song. A lot of people recognized it from Twitter and, you know, it starts to catch on. So this is before it's even reinforced in a match. It's just out in the bar.
而要做到这一点，你需要一个火种。我总是说，只需要一个傻瓜站出来引吭高歌，其他人就会跟着唱。所以那是我的另一个朋友，在往后好几排的地方，我能听到的只有他在唱这首歌。他叫基兰·巴里，我能听到他到处都在大声唱着这首歌。随着时间推移，越来越多的球迷加入了进来，
Right, right. And so Dan left the bar and the song kept spreading from there. On the walk into the stadium, and the song kept spreading from there. On the walk into the stadium, he heard more people singing it. But the big question was whether he and his friends could get the song going during an actual match, like in the stadium.
很快这首新歌就在球场里回荡起来。人们开始自发合唱，接着当厄德高在比赛结束时走过来时，大家冲着他唱起这首歌，歌声变得越来越大。然后，当厄德高在比赛结束时走过来时，大家冲着他唱起这首歌，歌声变得越来越大。（背景中播放着大黄蜂乐队的《欢乐颂》并伴随合唱。）太棒了。
And for that to happen, you need a spark. I always say it takes one idiot to stand out for the rest to sing. So it was another one of my friends quite a few rows back, and all I could hear was him singing the song. His name's Kieran Barry and I could just hear him shouting the song everywhere. Over time, more and more fans joined him
看到他认可大家的所作所为，这种感觉真的很棒，你懂我的意思吗？在这段视频里，厄德高看着他们，跟着一起鼓掌什么的。太棒了。对啊，完全如此。想象一下，你在你的工作岗位上，有成千上万的人深爱着你，无比渴望你能把工作做好，他们就在那里为你创作了一首专属的颂歌，专门为你而唱。听着，有六万人高喊着你的名字并为你所做的一切向你致敬，这一定是一种非常特别的感觉。
and pretty soon this new song was echoing around the stadium. People just started singing it and then as Erdogan came over at the end of the game, people were singing it to him and it just went louder and louder. And then as Odegaard came over at the end of the game, people were singing it to him, and it just went louder and louder. ["Ode to Joy!" by The Bumblebee Band playing and chanting in background.] It's so great.
是的，但对于词作家来说，看到这一切真正流行起来，也一定是一种相当奇妙的感觉吧？对，完全是这样。我跟丹多次聊过这个话题，他对此显得非常害羞和谦逊，但你知道的，这对我来说简直太疯狂了。比如，我都不敢去猜现在全球到底有多少人会唱这首歌的歌词，
It's so great to see him recognize what they're doing. You know what I mean? In this video, you know, Odegaard is like watching them and clapping along and stuff. So great. Yeah, totally. I mean, imagine you're like at your workplace and there's thousands of people who love you and really badly want you to be doing a good job and they're just like singing this devotional
但绝对是个庞大的数字。就在几天前，我去旧金山的一家酒吧看比赛，马丁·厄德高进球了，旧金山卡利福尼亚的这家酒吧里的所有人，居然都开始齐声合唱这首歌——这首歌可是丹在一年左右前创作的。这简直是一首全球认证的排行榜冠军单曲。对，没错。它成白金唱片了。但你知道的，我觉得贯穿这一切最让我惊叹的是，丹和他的朋友们对他们创作的歌曲其实一点也不矫情。他们认为自己的角色，大概就是不断产出各种灵感，然后看看哪个能真正留存下来。
song that they created, especially for you. Listen, it must be a very special feeling to have 60,000 people singing your name and saluting you for what you do. Yeah, but it also must be a pretty amazing feeling for the songwriters to see this take off, you know? Yeah, completely. And I brought this up with Dan a lot, and he's very kind of bashful and humble about it, but, you know, it's wild to me. Like, I would hesitate to guess the number of people who know the words to that song, like, globally at this point,
他们深知自己想出的绝大多数点子最后都会石沉大海，但这正是这个过程的一部分。想象一下那些没能流行起来的歌曲，某个人站起来试图起头，结果却鸦雀无声，这种场景其实也挺好玩的。完全如此。我的意思是，我觉得这种事简直无时无刻不在发生。当时有一首歌是改编自小红莓乐队的《Zombie》的名曲。哦，当然。
but it is a lot. Like, just the other day, I went to watch a game at a bar in San Francisco and Martin Odegaard scored and this entire bar in San Francisco in California starts singing the song that Dan wrote a couple, you know, a year or so ago. It's a worldwide global number one hit. Yeah, exactly. He went platinum. But you know, I think that a thing that has struck me throughout this is just how un-precious Dan and his friends are about their songwriting. They see their role, I think, is just to churn out lots of ideas and sort of see what sticks.
是写给一位名叫加布里埃尔的阿森纳后卫的。对。哦，真的吗？对。我想，他的绰号叫加比。加比，加比。你会觉得，对吧，这具备了一首热单所有的成功要素。但显然，它最终导致的结果只是有一个家伙在足球看台上一遍又一遍地声嘶力竭大喊着“加比”这个词，
They know that most of the ideas that they come up with won't go anywhere, but that's just part of the process. It's kind of fun to imagine the ones that don't take off where somebody does stand up and try to start it and then nothing happens. Totally. I mean, I think that happens literally all the time. There was one to the tune of a song called Zombie by the Cranberries. Oh, of course.
直到他最终被大家无视，甚至可能因为安保人员担心他的身心健康而被带离了现场。那可真够丢脸的。但我完全能想象得出那个画面，简直绝了。我确信他没事。不过加布里埃尔最终还是拥有了一首专属歌曲。而且说来也巧，丹和他的朋友们也参与了这首歌的创作。基本上在几个赛季前，曾有球迷试图以标准旋律起头弄一首加布里埃尔的歌。
About an Arsenal defender called Gabrielle. Yeah. Oh, really? Yeah. I think it was, his nickname is Gabby. Gabby, Gabby. And you would think, right, that's got all the ingredients to make a success. But apparently it just resulted in one guy just basically just screaming the word Gabby
虽然没真正流行起来，但这些歌词在接下来的几年里经过不同人的反复修改。到了2024年，加布里埃尔迎来了状态极其神勇的一个赛季，丹和他的朋友们决定，我们无论如何也要让这首歌火起来。现在这家伙绝对配得上一首专属歌曲了。
over and over again in a football stadium until he was eventually ignored or possibly even taken away by stewards who were concerned for his wellbeing. That would be mortifying. But I could totally imagine it perfectly. I'm sure he was fine. Gabrielle did eventually get a song though. And weirdly, Dan and his friends were involved in this one too. Basically a few seasons ago, a fan had tried to get a Gabrielle song going to the standard
于是他们发布了一段视频，画面里是他们这帮伙计在客场比赛归来的火车上高唱这首歌。这一次，这首歌彻底火遍了全网。他是来自巴西的国王，我们的防线中坚加布里埃尔，我们的后防定海神针加布里埃尔。奥莱，奥莱，奥莱，奥莱，奥莱，奥莱，奥莱，奥莱·迪，奥雷奥拉。
tune. And it didn't really take, but the lyrics got tweaked a little bit by different people over the years. And then in 2024, Gabriel was just, he was having this incredible season, and Dan and his friends decided, like, we really need to make this song happen. Now this guy deserves a song.
奥雷奥迪，奥雷奥迪，奥雷奥拉。所以这首歌现在已经成了经典歌单的一部分了吗？你在旧金山的酒吧里也能听到吗？对，绝对能。你随时都能听到。我的意思是，这真的凸显了整个过程是多么具有集体性。我的意思是，那个最先想出点子的人
And they posted a video of their crew singing, singing this Gabriel song on the train, on the way back from an away match. And this time it just went everywhere. The six is the King of Brazil, our center of El Jai Gual, our world at the back is Gabrielle. Ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole, ole dee, oreo la.
其实只是迈出了第一步。最终决定什么歌能被收录进歌集的，终究还是群众的智慧。对，我觉得完全就是这样。而且我认为这种集体主义精神正是欧洲足球极其重要的组成部分。作为一个球迷，真正意味着你要为围绕你所支持俱乐部的文化做出贡献。你不仅仅是在消费这个娱乐产品，
Oreo dee, oreo dee, oreo la. And so is this song part of the canon? Would you hear this in a bar in San Francisco? Yeah, absolutely. You hear it all the time. I mean, it really underscores how collective this whole process is. I mean, the person who comes up with an idea
你是有工作要做的。对。我想这就是为什么你经常听到球迷被称为“支持者”（supporters）。这非常有趣。我的意思是，阿森纳俱乐部自己也总是称大家为支持者，而不是普通球迷（fans）。他们希望他们的支持者能够积极参与进来。他们希望支持者能够制造出声浪，点燃看台上的歌声。每场比赛开球前一个小时零十五分钟，我们就已经到达现场了。如果我没有按时到场，也就是提前一个小时零十五分钟，就会有人发信息问我：你在哪儿？
is just the very first step. And it really is the wisdom of a crowd that ultimately determines what makes it into the songbook. Yeah, I think that's exactly right. And I think that that collective mentality is just a really important part of European football. Being a fan really means contributing to the culture around your club. You're not just consuming this entertainment product,
你怎么还没来？你上班迟到了。你上班迟到了。对。感觉确实就像上班一样。这唯一的目的就是为了激励球迷们高唱，让现场气氛更加热烈，并最终让球迷、让支持者去对球场上的球员产生影响。这是我们唯一能做的、去影响他们的方式，那就是制造噪音，试图激励他们、为他们呐喊助威。所以在我们结束之前，阿森纳这个赛季表现得怎么样？起起伏伏吧。在我们录制这期节目时，他们在联赛中排名第二，这当然很棒，但大家总有一种感觉：
you have a job to do. Yeah. And I think that's why you often hear fans referred to as supporters. It's very interesting. I mean Arsenal themselves always talk about supporters rather than fans. They want their supporters to be actively engaged. They want them to be, you know, making that noise, firing up that choir. We get there an hour and a quarter earlier than kick off every single game. If I'm not there on time, an hour and a quarter before, I get people messaging saying, where are you?
他们本可以表现得更好，而且他们整个赛季都在艰难应对一些非常、非常严重的伤病问题，这当然很棒。但大家总有一种感觉，他们本可以表现得更好。而且他们整个赛季都在艰难应对一些非常、非常严重的伤病问题，其中包括凯·哈弗茨。对。所以你已经很久没听到《Waka Waka》这首歌了。对。对。已经好几个星期没听到Waka Waka了。
Why are you not here? You're late to work. You're late to work. Yeah. It can feel like that. It's only with the intention of making fans sing and get the atmosphere going louder and ultimately trying to have as a fan, as a supporter, an influence on the players on the pitch. That's the only thing we can do to influence them is to make noise and try and inspire them and cheer them on. So before we go, how is Arsenal doing this season? It's been up and down. As we record this, they're in second place in the league, which is great, but there's a feeling
你怎么没来？你上班迟到了。你上班迟到了。是的。感觉确实是这样。这么做只是为了让球迷们歌唱，让现场气氛更热烈，最终作为球迷、作为支持者，去影响球场上的球员。这是我们能做的唯一一件能影响他们的事情，那就是制造噪音，试着激励他们，为他们呐喊助威。所以在我们离开之前，阿森纳本赛季表现如何？经历了起伏。在我们录制的时候，他们排在联赛第二，这很棒，但有一种感觉
that they could have done even better, and they've had to cope with some really, really tough injuries throughout the league, which is great. But there's a feeling that they could have done even better. And they've had to cope with some really, really tough injuries throughout the season, including Takai Havertz. Yeah. So you've not heard the Waka Waka song in a long time. Yeah. Yeah. There's been no Waka Waka for weeks now.
他们本可以表现得更好，而且整个赛季他们不得不应对一些非常非常严重的伤病，这很棒。但有一种感觉是，他们本可以表现得更好。而且整个赛季他们都不得不应对一些非常非常严重的伤病，包括哈弗茨。是的。所以你已经很久没听到《Waka Waka》这首歌了。是的。是的。已经好几周没有《Waka Waka》了。
And for a little while, the atmosphere at the stadium really has felt kind of quiet. But about a week before this episode came out, Arsenal had this massive home game against Real Madrid in the quarterfinals of the Champions League. Real Madrid were the defending champions and probably the favorites to win the tournament again. But Arsenal managed to win that game 3-0, and then beat Madrid again to advance to the semifinals. 3-0 and then beat Madrid again to advance to the semi-finals.
在有一段时间里，体育场的气氛确实显得有点安静。但在本集播出大约一周前，阿森纳在欧冠四分之一决赛中迎来了对阵皇家马德里的关键主场比赛。皇马是卫冕冠军，也可能是再次赢得这项赛事的夺冠热门。但阿森纳以3比0赢下了那场比赛，随后又击败皇马晋级半决赛。3比0取胜后再胜皇马，成功晋级半决赛。
And I don't think you can give the supporters all of the credit, but I will say, even through the TV, you could tell the crowd inside that stadium was as loud as it's ever been. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald and edited by Kelly Prime. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real, George Langford, and APM. Fact-checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks this week to Ben Bennett.
虽然不能把所有的功劳都归功于球迷，但我想说，即使是通过电视屏幕，你也能听出球场内的欢呼声是有史以来最大的一次。《99% Invisible》本周由 Emmett Fitzgerald 制作，Kelly Prime 编辑。混音由 Martin Gonzalez 负责。音乐由 Swan Real、George Langford 和 APM 提供。事实核查由 Graham Hayesha 完成。本周特别感谢 Ben Bennett。
Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barupe, Jason DeLeon, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north
Cathy Tu 是我们的执行制片人。Kurt Kolstad 是数字总监。Delaney Hall 是我们的资深编辑。团队其他成员包括 Chris Barupe、Jason DeLeon、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Ley、Lashma Dawn、Joe Rosenberg、Jacob Medina Gleason，以及我，Roman Mars。99% 的标志由 Stefan Lawrence 创建。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，总部现在位于北边六个街区
in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. work. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽上城潘多拉大厦内。您可以在 Blue Sky 以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有指向该服务器以及 99PI 每一期过往节目的链接。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。